this problem somehow got under my skin
it seemed so obvious yet it resisted all
my attempts to prove it
it was just stubbornness on my part that
I didn't want to take no for an answer
so I kept going
to me math is really about connections
between things that seem totally
unrelated
and it's sort of always bare for you
my name is Daniel Larson I'm a freshman
at MIT and I'm studying mathematics
when I was in high school I got
interested in Carmichael numbers
[Music]
a Carmichael number is a number n such
that for all integers a a to the N minus
a is divisible by n and furthermore this
is where it gets interesting n is not
Prime
so the way you construct harm like the
numbers is you build them out of prime
factors which have a special property
but the problem is it's difficult to say
in advance how many prime factors these
numbers will have and without knowing
how many prime factors they have it's
difficult to get an exact read on the
size
version is postulate for primes says
that for every large number there exists
a prime between that number and it's
double and so we would like to say the
same thing is true for Carmichael
numbers
so what I did is I made use of this
great breakthrough from a few years ago
by John Maynard which was actually about
looking at small gaps between primes and
it's this incredibly exciting new
technique and number Theory
I had many ideas about the problem but
none of them went anywhere until I
realized that I could use these results
about gaps between primes and I was able
to apply that to the study of Carmichael
numbers
I showed that for sufficiently large n
there exist comical numbers between n
and 2N
I still wasn't 100 sure that I hadn't
made a mistake somewhere so I sent the
paper to Granville who was one of the
leading experts on this field I got this
manuscript from a person I didn't know
called Daniel Lawson and it was a little
technical but it had ideas it had real
ideas it's always a bit surprising when
you get something really good from
someone you've never heard of but then
to find out that he's 17 in high school
was mind-blowing
one thing I think is interesting about
my proof is that it really relies on
Fourier analysis which is a theory from
physics about decomposing functions into
waves foreign
set of objects and you want to study
subsets with some particular nice
property where you analysis lets you
study the set of subsets of the objects
and so that gives you this sort of tree
of possibilities expanding from this set
and now with very basic statements about
the trunk of that tree Fourier analysis
lets you make very expansive claims
about the branches my problem the trunk
was a certain set of prime numbers and I
wanted to show that you could sort of
predict the location of the apples or
the Carmichael numbers
there are many questions we still don't
know the answer to about Carmichael
numbers and actually some of them are
very relevant for cryptography modern
cryptography uses really large primes to
decrypt messages and so to find really
large primes the best thing to do is
just test random numbers for primality
and the problem is these Carmichael
numbers can register as primes even
though they're not and that can lead to
weaker messages so we would like to
understand Carmichael numbers better so
that we can avoid weaker encryption
one thing I really appreciated is I have
been hearing the names Maynard Granville
for palmerance for so many years these
are like Legends but you know a random
person emailed them and they responded
and they looked at the work and I'm just
so incredibly grateful he was doing work
at the level of a top quality PhD
student this super surprised me I mean
this is definitely
out of the ordinary even for you know
the US has a couple of prodigies every
year in mathematics right but but he's
exceptional even amongst them
I think this is really a great thing
about the number Theory community that
people are so welcoming and supportive
of new people trying to get into it so
you know I encourage everybody to try
their hand at various problems and you
know don't be afraid to write these big
names they will write back
foreign